Musique dynamique
...
-C'est l'instantanéité.
Tout, tout de suite.
-Le fait
qu'on livre rapidement
ne signifie pas qu'on pousse
nos livreurs à aller vite.
-Il fallait aller très vite.
-Ils sont sur les trottoirs,
ils conduisent partout,
n'importe où.
-C'est le dark store
qui s'est installé
dans une copro
en utilisant les règlements...
Le flou des réglementations.
-Il faut mettre en place
des règles.
...
-Maud Gatel,
je suis députée de Paris,
élue
des 6e et 14e arrondissements.
Je travaille depuis plusieurs mois
sur la question
de la livraison
de courses alimentaires,
de plats préparés,
c'est-à-dire le quick commerce,
dans le cadre d'une mission
d'information de l'Assemblée.
Ce phénomène s'est développé
depuis le dernier confinement
dans les grandes métropoles
et à Paris.
Musique tonique
-Ils ont envahi
la capitale
avec leur cadence infernale.
Des coursiers à vélo ou à scooter
qui vous livrent en un temps record
vos produits du quotidien.
Ils travaillent
pour Flink, Getir
ou encore Frichti.
Ces commerces font de la vitesse
leur promesse de vente.
Pour livrer
plus vite que les autres,
ces acteurs ont implanté
un type de magasins inédit
un peu partout
dans la capitale,
des dark stores,
soit des magasins de l'ombre.
En réalité,
il s'agit d'entrepôts
où sont stockés les produits
et d'où partent les commandes.
La députée va en visiter un,
inaccessible au public.
-Bonjour.
-Bonjour, madame la députée.
-Dans ce dark store,
ce matin-là,
deux préparateurs
traitent vite les commandes.
Il leur faut trois minutes
en moyenne, car tout est optimisé.
-Quand une commande arrive,
il va y avoir un son
sur l'outil du préparateur.
Il va prendre un chariot
de préparation.
On a un chemin
qui est toujours le même,
qui permet aux préparateurs
de se suivre.
-Une fois la commande préparée,
elle part directement en livraison,
récupérée par un coursier,
un salarié de l'entreprise,
qui va la livrer à vélo
ou à scooter.
-Est-ce qu'il y a une limite ?
Vous ne vous dites pas
qu'à partir de 20 kilos,
on fait deux livraisons
au lieu d'une seule ?
-La limite est calculée
en nombre de contenants.
Un vélo, avec les outils
qu'on a aujourd'hui,
deux sacoches sur les côtés
et un top-case derrière,
on a, mécaniquement...
-Vous êtes limités.
-On est limités par les contenants.
-Pas en poids.
Donc là,
pour stocker les vélos...
-Exactement.
-En permanence, ils sont là.
Ils sont pas dehors.
-C'est un point qui nous est cher.
Au démarrage,
on avait des sujets
sur les livreurs
qui patientaient à l'extérieur
ou des vélos stockés
à l'extérieur.
Maintenant,
la politique,
c'est que le livreur
attende à l'intérieur.
-Des vélos bien rangés
et qui ici sont 100 % électriques.
Tout semble en ordre,
mais une subtilité n'a pas échappé
à la députée :
d'autres véhicules
stationnent dehors,
ceux de livreurs Uber Eats.
Maud Gatel demande
des explications.
-On est partenaire
de Carrefour,
donc on prépare des commandes
pour leur compte,
pour le service
Carrefour Sprint,
qui sont des magasins
sur la plateforme Uber Eats.
-Ces livreurs Uber Eats
sont sur des scooters thermiques
qui polluent énormément.
Pour ce qui est
de l'occupation
de l'espace public,
votre responsabilité
est quand même sous-jacente,
dans la mesure
où c'est parce que vous êtes ici
qu'ils viennent chercher
des commandes à livrer.
-Un sujet qui,
dans l'esprit de la députée,
est directement lié
à un autre :
la nature de ces locaux.
Musique cocasse
-Est-ce que vous avez prévenu
la direction de l'urbanisme
de Paris de votre installation
et fait la demande
de changement de destination ?
Si c'était un magasin,
aujourd'hui, c'est pas un magasin
dans le sens où y a pas de gens
qui rentrent à l'intérieur.
Est-ce que vous avez fait
des démarches ?
-Nous, on défend
que nous sommes des magasins,
enfin, un commerçant classique.
On a des produits en stock,
on a des clients qui achètent
depuis l'application,
donc pour un certain nombre
de raisons...
Après, voilà,
encore une fois, on est...
On reste à disposition
pour échanger là-dessus
et pour trouver une solution...
Pour trouver une solution.
-Moi, je considère
qu'à partir du moment
où il n'y a pas
de public qui rentre,
ce sont des zones de stockage
et pas des magasins.
-Zones de stockage
ou magasins ?
Pour la députée,
ce n'est pas la même chose
et elle n'est pas la seule
à le penser.
Un peu plus à l'ouest
de la capitale,
elle va rencontrer un maire
en colère.
-Monsieur le maire.
-Il caille pas trop ?
-Non, ça va.
-Geoffroy Boulard a vu
ce dark store s'implanter
en bas de cet immeuble
d'habitations
en se présentant
comme un commerce traditionnel.
-Ici, on est
dans l'exemple du dark store
qui s'est installé
dans une copro
en détournant...
Il hésite.
En utilisant les règlements,
le flou des réglementations.
-Ca doit lui valoir,
d'ailleurs, des astreintes...
-Assez peu. Assez peu.
-D'accord.
-Résultat :
depuis plus d'un an,
à l'unisson de ses habitants,
Geoffroy Boulard ne décolère pas.
Tout n'est pas aussi rose
que le déclare Flink.
Premier constat ici :
les vélos stationnent
sur la voie publique,
et ce n'est pas le seul souci.
-Bonjour, madame.
Vous vouliez nous parler.
-Vous êtes gênée par...
-Mes voisins,
qui habitent également le 2e,
parce que j'habite au 2e étage,
sont très, très dérangés
par le bruit, etc.
-Et donc, c'est quoi ?
C'est le bruit,
les va-et-vient,
les livreurs qui attendent ?
-Absolument, oui,
et puis, même, de toute façon,
ils conduisent
dans le sens inverse du...
-Tout à fait.
-Ils sont sur les trottoirs,
ils conduisent n'importe où,
enfin, c'est... grave.
-On a une part de responsabilité,
nous, consommateurs.
-Oui, au niveau des modes
de consommation, tout change.
-Ultra rapide...
-Livraisons à domicile,
tout ultra rapide.
-Bien sûr.
-C'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui,
ils privilégient
la centralité
pour faire en sorte
d'être sur une livraison
de 10 à 15 minutes
aux dépens, en fait,
du caractère adapté ou non
de l'environnement
dans lequel ils s'installent.
-Pour éviter d'être de nouveau
pris de court à l'avenir,
le maire réclame donc
de nouveaux moyens.
-Le PLU, le plan local d'urbanisme,
ça suffit pas.
C'est pour ça que j'avais dit
au gouvernement :
"Il faut aller plus loin, il faut
donner un permis d'installation"
et on donne
ou on donne pas.
-C'est ça, en amont.
C'est en amont et pas après.
-Il faut des garde-fous et il faut
donner quand même de la liberté,
Dire qu'on va faire une ville zéro
dark store, c'est utopique.
C'est un nouveau
mode de consommation,
il faut le réguler
et il faut le faire vite.
Sinon,
on va être débordés
et c'est bon
pour personne, en fait.
-Ces problèmes,
la députée les a rencontrés
pour la première fois
dans sa circonscription.
Alertée par des riverains
du 14e arrondissement qui se sont
organisés en collectif,
excédés par les nuisances
d'un dark store
dans leur rue
auparavant très calme.
-On voit des livreurs
sur les trottoirs.
-Ils ont des voitures
et ils mettent la musique
dans les voitures et...
Voilà, ça fait en plus...
En plus des conversations, du bruit.
-Ah oui, d'accord.
-C'était non-stop
toute la journée.
-Là, on a à la fois
des livreurs Flink...
-Et des salariés.
-Donc salariés
et des livreurs Uber.
Ah oui ! Oh !
Alors... Là, c'est un scooter
qui roule à toute blinde
sur le minuscule trottoir
devant le store.
Le sujet : est-ce que
ça s'intègre bien dans le quartier ?
La réponse est non.
-Il faudrait pas que ce soit
dans des zones d'habitation,
dans des sous-sols,
dans des lieux adaptés
mais pas comme nous,
à même la rue.
-Ils se croient tout permis.
Ils savent bien qu'ils n'ont pas
respecté les règles.
Voilà, ils le savent, donc...
-Pour la députée,
si ces installations
ont pu se faire,
c'est que
ces nouveaux acteurs ont pris
de court les pouvoirs publics
et imposé une logique
qu'il est grand temps d'inverser.
-En 1, c'est le périmètre
de livraison,
en 2, c'est l'opérationnalité,
l'exploitation,
et en 3, c'est le voisinage.
Le 3, il doit passer en 1
parce que c'est ça, le sujet.
-Ca commence par ça.
-Il est temps
de mettre en place des règles,
des conventions collectives,
des règles
par rapport aux commerces
d'éviter les distorsions
de concurrence.
-Sauf qu'en attendant,
c'est un peu l'anarchie.
A quelques mètres de là,
les riverains emmènent la députée
devant le magasin
qui hante leurs jours
et leurs nuits.
-A l'intérieur, je crois
qu'ils n'ont pas de réseau
pour téléphoner,
donc tous les coups de fil
persos, ça se fait ici.
En plein hiver,
il y en a moins,
mais l'été,
c'est insupportable.
Il y a un petit salon
qui est installé
et ça crie.
-Une jeune personne
qui habitait au...
-Ici. Là où c'est fermé.
-Oui.
-...a déménagé,
elle n'arrivait plus à dormir.
-Et ces scooters qui rôdent,
qui ont leur tuyau
d'échappement traficoté,
c'est insupportable.
Y a rien
qui les freine.
-Ils travaillent
dans des conditions
inadmissibles.
-Oui, je les plains aussi
parce qu'ils sont sur leur vélo
à porter des litres et litres d'eau,
à se casser le dos, mais voilà.
-Les conditions de travail
des livreurs, c'est un autre sujet
qui interpelle la députée.
-Bonjour !
-Pour savoir ce que cache
cette course à la vitesse,
Maud Gatel va écouter le témoignage
de coursiers dans ce local syndical.
-Vous pouvez me parler
de vos conditions de travail ?
Les gens peuvent vous demander
de livrer 20 kg ? 25 kg ?
-Plus, même.
-Tu peux avoir une commande
avec deux packs d'eau
et d'autres aliments
qui accompagnent
et si tu dis rien, le magasinier,
il va te faire livrer tout ça.
"Si tu as un sac,
tu peux le porter.
"Vas-y, tu as un sac,
tu peux le porter."
-"Prenez votre temps",
mais après,
c'était la course
contre la montre.
Du coup, c'était dangereux
parce qu'on est tombés...
On est tombés beaucoup de fois,
quand même, sur la route.
-La formation sur la sécurité
routière, c'était quoi ?
Ca consistait en quoi ?
-Ah, la formation...
C'était juste en mode
on arrive,
on sait parler français,
on sait conduire un vélo.
On doit faire
une allée en vélo et revenir.
C'était juste ça,
la formation pour les vélos.
-Derrière
ces conditions de travail
se cache aussi
un modèle à deux vitesses.
Les livreurs des dark stores
sont salariés,
les coursiers Uber Eats
sont autoentrepreneurs
sans couverture sociale.
Comme Amidou, ils sont aussi
souvent sans papiers.
-Sur quoi
vous vous battez ?
-On essaie de pouvoir
travailler normalement
pour être régularisés,
pouvoir rouler et nous occuper
de nos différentes familles.
Je suis arrivé chez Uber
en 2019...
-D'accord.
-...et avec
les locations de comptes...
-Une location de compte,
car pour pouvoir travailler,
Amidou, comme d'autres
livreurs sans papiers,
sous-loue le compte Uber
d'une autre personne.
-Vous l'avez payé combien,
ce compte ?
-C'était 100 euros par semaine.
-100 euros par semaine ?
Vous savez un peu le profil des gens
qui louent leur compte ?
-Non, pas vraiment.
-Pardon,
mais c'est dégueulasse aussi.
-Les plus gros exploiteurs,
pardonnez-moi l'expression,
parce qu'ils sont
au courant du système,
ça reste les plateformes.
-Des plateformes
qui se sont massivement
séparées de livreurs
ces derniers mois.
Moussa estime avoir été
licencié abusivement
par Getir. Pour Amidou, les choses
ont été encore plus simples :
il y a quelques mois,
il a vu son compte Uber suspendu
du jour au lendemain
par l'application.
-La première des mesures,
c'est la déconnexion massive.
-Pourquoi ils ont fait ça,
à votre avis ?
-Avec le Covid, ils avaient vraiment
besoin de livreurs, c'était vital,
il fallait des gens
pour aller livrer
aux gens qui étaient bloqués
chez eux et tout ça.
Du coup, là, je trouve
qu'ils se sont servis de nous
et là, ils en ont plus besoin,
ils s'en débarrassent.
-Vous avez des droits.
Vous avez des droits.
Il faut les faire respecter, voilà.
Y a des tas de gens
qui se sont battus pour,
et les nouveaux droits,
on va se battre pour.
C'est vraiment important.
-Des nouveaux droits
et des nouveaux devoirs
que Maud Gatel compte écrire
rapidement dans une loi,
consciente que
pour le législateur aussi
se joue une course de vitesse.
Musique légère
...
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA